this week we've got honorary degree lava
bomb and crazy shootout where's my
gunner yes the progress story there's
this mom in Turkey that received an
honorary law degree because she helped
her blind daughter study the lecture
notes during her four-year course
oh oh oh that's a cool they hand out
degrees like that in Turkey that's kind
of scary
you you helped your kid go through
Medical School you two are a doctor
you're a doctor and you're a doctor
you're a doctor doctor everybody
turkey doctors it's kind of scary she
read everything to her daughter uh so
she's basically studying the same exact
thing but it doesn't mean that if again
America you would have to still pass the
bar but it's honorary practice she can't
practice yeah it's like being an
honorary fireman you can't do nothing
you just get a certificate or some [ __ ]
sticker yeah exactly so they're just
acknowledging like hey you know you
deserve something out of all the hard
work you put in to help your daughter
their definition of an honorary means
that it doesn't work well even ours it's
just it's it's it basically means like
you could participation you're a pretend
doctor your pretend it's so in human
terms like when we have such as turkey
it's it's just like oh this is a cute
gesture to give you just to show some
appreciation for you being a kind good
mama to your daughter but it doesn't
mean anything but we're just like cuz in
America you can't be honoring policemen
and now you start caring a gun anyway so
we're not you know without carrying your
it's the word honorary it doesn't mean
that you're official it's honor it's
yeah you're fake cuz in some
circumstances when it's honoring you
have full benefits like when like most
of that most of the time that I hear it
it's like okay your honor marry like
Automator this
or whatever you have full benefits of it
it's actually the minority of me hearing
your honor
oh and it's just a name it's like if
you're an auditory Edward when you're a
batterer airy and word then you can say
the word Edward I still want to say I'm
too scared okay but we're not gonna
costs over the fact that her daughter is
a blind lawyer like in daredevil oh
hello that's right I don't even remember
yeah I see I choose a blind doctor
because of Bart's example this whole
time I'm like I forgot about the lawyers
how is she gonna perform surgery with
that blind as [ __ ] doctors use the
blind plastic surgeon like yes your
titties seem even yes it's like one up
one day it's a [ __ ] cheap dude
there's a whole bunch of Teddy doctor
videos all over YouTube and that [ __ ]
you pervert that [ __ ] is surgical that's
just like the surgical you nasty pervert
I mean it's literal surgical no meaning
like there's no it's not a tip it's
telling a ten if you cut it open you
pervert you know and you look at a tip
is it before it the tenth after is this
his it's so sterile but you know this is
like oh like the doctor clubs the doctor
cuddle he goes it is not flat you know
but it's like he's like touchy like it's
nothing I thought that happened to her
it was weird
the doctor just goes all the buttons fly
off and he starts going like this and my
butt and then he put me on the table
yeah
I do not want to intervene but this
medical procedure is weird and then he
like started from the bottom and he like
was like I was going like this in order
for me to do this professionally I need
to put my dick inside of you he wasn't
an honorary doctor though he's a real
one there's a guy on YouTube I know he's
a guy agent do but he's like so serious
you know until I get he's kind of like
as he looking at the group he goes mmm
okay yeah it's just so like if I saw a
million titties
by that time it won't even faze me I
don't know if he'll excite me the same
what it is yeah it's like he's obese
today I wouldn't be scared to date a
plastic surgeon because the first time
we literally dude that's not like a
racist Japanese nicknamed it Chuck
Japanese people during the [ __ ]
observe and get exactly tip Chuck if
they're named Charles when the doctor
like starts drawing on the boobies it
looks like a basketball game plan yeah
just some plays and [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna
run from the left nipple to the right
and we're gonna play it it's like dodge
it looks like a half-court and then
we're gonna do the play is just right
all right for a next story
yeah you guys know that volcano it's
been erupting in ho yeah is it still
going until when we first did this video
about this and I was like what's the big
deal why always have act active
volcanoes I had no not like this the
severity of it which island isn't on the
island the ones that that did it Rupp or
whatever there's like this one video of
[ __ ] lava flow like a river like like
a whitewater [ __ ] rafting crazy ass
it's like you know you know how
opportune people are like there's like a
whole new subcategory now of throwing
things in lava and seeing how it reacts
mm-hmm I'd be curious to that'sa danijon
exact because I watched it all night
yesterday is dope and it clicking steak
and lava cooking with throwing a tire
lava the kind of beans and lava what
happens and I was like what happens it
just melt it just explodes but then I
literally the video was like eight
minutes long and I waited the whole time
it takes eight minutes for a can of
beans explode because the lavas reaching
it the can of beans is next to the lava
and it slowly goes no the ones that you
see like in Hawaii with lava or is it
like manufactured love manufactured like
a test like hot molten multi yeah like
they're using this as an opportunity to
get to make views and create content
well they're gonna run out of content
because [ __ ] that lavas gonna stop
flowing one day but if they're
stockpiling oh yeah they have what's it
called they put like a monster energy
drink in there what I've been doing it
exploded
it exploded every single one is explode
was it explode and then a bunch of
liquid or it cuz it's so hot it went
like it I'm rated super fast and then
the can actually caught on fire Wow do
you think cookie really put a hot dog on
a stick and just there's a video where
these people hide like molten rock which
is like man-made love like yeah that's
the one I've seen got it yeah they cook
steak they cook weird [ __ ] or even like
see unless you like the hydraulic press
Channel I wash I should yeah I can't
watch that's oddly satisfying [ __ ] oh
they take it they like vacuum every all
the entire air out and then you see
things like yeah I don't know what I
like about it though I don't know why I
liked watching things going to lava oh I
mean I think is the same thing as like
when you have a campfire and you like
throwing random [ __ ] in there like how
about this branch how about this [ __ ]
rocks they have like certain like they
have these certain things I know this
guy who can make explosives and they
have like this powder you throw in it
and the fire turns green and then blue
and then purple it's really well see
that that makes more sense it's just
like the reason why I stopped because I
start feeling really stupid is because I
could have just fast forward it they're
just watching it like the [ __ ] upload
bar takes a long time man what movie was
that [ __ ] when the car was coming at him
and he was like no that's what it felt
like and then I stopped watching imagine
you sitting there watching it 3:00 in
the morning drool coming down your face
[ __ ] watching Italy the bomb went off
and an injured 23 people they're trying
to close the lava hole here we go that's
exactly what they calling vagina Oh
what that's more mash it injured 23
people yeah a few big chunks that was on
the roof one man on the floor why are
they so close they were looking at the
lava to close dams Benson's me yes me I
think the the eruption happened a wave
like a closer - yeah [ __ ] it I'm not
gonna explain I commend you for it I
commend you for it got tired of thinking
I was like I know what's in my head I'm
a temp explaining okay there's what all
right so the labra and the action was
happening here but sometimes what ends
up happening is the mother [ __ ] lava
goes under and it goes up like this so
so here's the ocean right here's the
ocean this is where the action is
happening visually above ground you can
put the boat here you can see it but
sometimes the lava goes underneath like
that and explodes upwards like that that
was such a simple explanation it's hard
to do that while you're watching and
enjoying it at the same you said like
people were talking over your sleep yeah
like people get interrupted interrupting
myself
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
he was busy [ __ ] anymore
you didn't want to listen is a talk at a
college or something are you with your
cell phone
actually interrupt I'm even gonna try
cuz I want to focus on the video right
that is only time in the past like seven
years we've done JK days where I've ever
heard you frustrated and even though we
passed this story already I forgot I'm
gonna show you a photo of the mom in the
plane but oh how are you win again
yes is the mom in the blinds dudx ona
degree affordable but anyways back to
the lava you know a Muslim nah they just
like scarves okay okay this is a Muslim
daredevil it's sick I'm so dope oh but
you can't work on Ramadan everybody dies
[Laughter]
always happens right before sunrise
because that's what they're praying and
then that's so bad or did you know that
you're facing it that way from the lava
from the lava they they got it a new
island I said the island use an acre
yeah clean you they added nearly seven
hundred acres to the Big Island Wow yeah
oh you know there's an extra eyelid
that's like unusable right by it and
then I sell it out to people they still
around a lot of lava yeah and then
there's even like moments where there's
like new land and then it goes into the
ocean oh isn't like new lava - that's
where a lot of new growth is because a
lot of the three ants oh yeah I think it
takes time though it's very fertile Oh
that'd be incredible that's why the
fruits are so good there huh volcanic
soil really yeah Wow
supposed to be like the [ __ ] anyway
moving on to our last story so there was
this crazy-ass real-life action
happening in Las Vegas there was a
shootout between cops and a murderer I
saw this this was wild okay let's watch
the video
okay Joe here we gotta what crying oh my
god check this out right out of the
movie as a cop fires through his own
windshield the drama started in morning
Russia the dramas as the officer chases
two murder suspects in the dark SUV up
ahead I didn't see there the fleeing
suspects even head into oncoming traffic
to make their getaway home started
shooting at him you can hear a barrage
of gunshots from the SUV OH
the officer is right behind the SUV when
he fires through the windshield
watch as he takes both hands off the
wheel and fires a second volley then is
out the side window it's like the Wild
West
it's crazy it all came to an end out of
all places an elementary school he got
him reload magazines Adrenaline's gone
and then he stopped them right man ago
that's what he killed him was killed in
the shootout the officer fired off a
total of 31 rounds the bad guys fired 34
Jesus yeah in your face they won when I
saw this video I am delicious real bro
like aside from obvious police what is
it when they force like excessive force
besides I mean aside from that I can
understand why they're so scared for
their lives all the time and why they
react 34 rounds see this side of
policing but this recently happened a
year ago right down the street at a
7-eleven right here there was a suspect
that was armed on a bicycle and he was
riding his bicycle and I think she was
pointing or shooting at the cops and
then the cop shot through the front yep
and so I understand why Lee here I was
like why are they so you say a window I
said Winship Jose like through the front
and you say a window and I was like
windshield because you said 7-eleven
7-eleven that's why I thought use like
inside 7-eleven shooting out the window
to try and get a snack and [ __ ] no he
was in the car slushy and that's crazy
I understand why they're so scared -
they're so intense all the time dude
this [ __ ] happens all the time it's just
not all of its reported so imagine all
the ones that happens like on the daily
that's not report and that's what
they're used to cops get shot for just
people over yeah that happens all the
time intense like that especially of
guys like
three striker he's already like done
with a warrant nothing to lose
yup yeah that's why there's so many like
Highway Patrol officer and cop names
like on the freeway because after every
time a cop gets killed from a pullover
or whatever whatever they have they
named the freeways after them there's
like so many times where they just pull
over a guy and then it's like a [ __ ]
armed guy you walk up [ __ ] armed
convict and he's like what what what and
then they drive off I want I follow the
guy just wanted this job at that point
dude all right
that's [ __ ] wild me do you watch
Brooklyn nine-nine no I don't watch TV
my father's a cop I'll be the person
that writes the tickets at the meter I
just want to be the guy that tells the
other cop that they're out of line and
I'm gonna take their badge away that's
the cop I want to be Oh turning your gun
in your badge my gun yeah I want the
chief that's a guy I want to be yeah me
Ron hell a fat with the moustache I
really don't do anything you just
drinking coffee all the time yeah
staying awake for no reason twenty
million dollars in damage and you didn't
even catch the perp yeah that's what I
want you probably imagine gun but it
wasn't my fault boss and then they go
and do the investigation anyways and
catch them without their best exactly
and then he's white chicks he doesn't
want to tell him a good job
but he doesn't yeah yeah you know I
thought was weird as they were shooting
in a residence alone yeah luckily no one
got injured mm-hmm I feel like he was
shooting when there was nobody else
around I think he was shooting after he
got shot yeah so I think it once the bad
guys start putting the rest of the
payday I take him out a public in danger
like being at to take him out I was
taking the shooting class and so there's
a guy he was a former Ranger and now
he's an LAPD SWAT and I was just asking
him which one is more difficult and he
was telling me being SWAT is way more
difficult because when you're a ranger
or Special Forces whatever overseas when
you see a bad guy with a gun you just
immediately unload until you eliminate
the threat right but then what's really
hard about being a cop is like let's say
you shoot him this guy if this guy if
you shoot him and he gets hit he drops
his gun any bullet after that is
considered excessive force
oh [ __ ] cops have to be extremely
cautious
weary but the thing is if he drops his
gun and you shoot him that's considered
excessive force but then if he grabs but
it is a huge possibility because once he
drops his gun you started lowering your
gun oh I don't want to have excessive
force that guy could pull up another
grunts you're constantly like oh my god
oh my god oh my god so it's really scary
but it was like overseas you just
eliminate the [ __ ] every person
you see just try to turn them into Swiss
cheese as many holes as possible as many
holes as possible as many holes as
possible you don't to worry about
restraint ya know my [ __ ] it's really
scary to be like wait okay you're
technically a threat no you're not a
threat you're a threat you're not a
threat so that's why that fools hella
like shaky he's like wait is he still
alive or he's gonna shoot at me and then
am I supposed to ride up take a pen on
or write a report and you have to
account for all shots overseas you don't
have to account for any shot they should
just give like chp a rocket launcher cuz
i was fast dude this one shot and the
guns gone right magical Gontier don't
work within the rules ever yeah I mean
you know two million dollars in damage
in you sprays and all the kids are
looking from the class good idea dude yo
i'ma blow your [ __ ] up if you don't call
the home did you see this full [ __ ]
through the moonroof as a [ __ ] rocket
launcher and then imma come up and
you'll see on the on the dashcam as I
arrest him but when I put his arms
behind his back a long just falls off to
charge [ __ ] drumsticks bodies to arms
or carry bucum Bukka
[Music]